ils ont travaillé plus de vingt ans
ensemble au sein de cette assemblée
l'un quitte son poste l'autre le
découvre dans un moment très solennel
jean le court go a été élu largement
nouveau maire de montigny le bretonneux
ce lundi 16 octobre à 67 ans avec 30 de
bulletins pour sur 37 le nouvel élu
souhaite se placer dans l'action de son
prédécesseur
moi je m'inscris complètement dans les
spas et de michel laugier encore une
fois comment pourrait-il en être
différemment puisque jusqu'à présent
tous les collègues de la liste ont voté
pour le programme qui a été le nôtre
donc oui c'est une continuité et pas du
tout une rupture
devenu sénateur fin septembre michel
laugier quitte donc un siège qu'il a
occupé pendant 13 ans ce conseil
municipal était aussi l'occasion pour
les élus de lui rendre un dernier
hommage
aujourd'hui les choses sont faites
quel nouveau maire
montigny-le-bretonneux à la tête de
l'équipe que j'ai eu l'honneur le
plaisir de conduire de sélectionner dont
je leur souhaite beaucoup de succès et
je serai toujours là avec un oeil
bienveillant
le nouvel organigramme municipal n'est
modifié qu'à la marge suzanne blanc
conserve ainsi son poste de première
adjointe en charge de la vie scolaire
yannick le dorze intègre lui l'exécutif
et devient responsable de la
communication une continuité qui ne
devrait pas bouleverser les relations
parfois tendues avec l'opposition
je pense qu'on a intérêt à continuer à
se battre sans relâche pour faire valoir
nos propositions allaient faire entendre
à les faire accepter parfois comme ça
parfois été le cas avec michel laugier
j'espère que ce sera le cas aussi là
avec avec jean-luc bourgault après on a
quelques désaccords quand même sur est
ce que montrent signé aujourd'hui est
une ville exemplaire en matière
d'écologie en matière de solidarité
après la mairie de montigny le
bretonneux une nouvelle élection aura
lieu jeudi prochain au sein du conseil
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour élire le
successeur de michel logis à la
présidence de la collectivité à poste
qui devrait revenir au maire d'elancourt
jean michel fourgous